foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story an intelligent and cheeky
girl loved by everyone the
eight-year-old who died in The Wimbledon
School crash is named as Selena Lao
a controversial decision from the United
States to send cluster Munitions to help
Ukraine on the battlefield
48 years in jail for the man who shot
and killed 26 year old Ellie Edwards in
a pub on merseyside you didn't care who
else would be killed
that's why you fired all of the bullets
at the group
I'm satisfied that you are a highly
dangerous man
the battle for AI Supremacy we report
from China on their race to dominate the
technology
the Palestinian militant tells Sky News
Israel's raids on the West Bank have
only deepened Defiance there
Belarus says it's ready to welcome
members of the Wagner mercenary group
but there's no sign of them yet
and have we seen the last shot from Andy
Murray at Wimbledon
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
front pages in our press preview from 10
30.
[Music]
good evening the eight-year-old girl who
died after a Land Rover crashed into the
grounds of her primary school in
Wimbledon has been named as Selena Lao
her family have described her as an
intelligent and cheeky girl adored and
loved by everyone another eight-year-old
girl is in a life-threatening condition
in hospital and a woman in her 40s is
also in a critical condition
ashnaharanag reports
the first glimpse of where a little
girl's life was cut short and where
another eight-year-old girl has now been
left in a life-threatening condition
this Gap where once stood a wooden fence
obscuring the school is now a window
into what happened
and mourners can't help but imagine the
horrors of Thursday morning
I'm looking at this
steel fence which has been put up and
in the place of a wooden fence that was
smashed on by a large Land Rover these
are very small old roads with narrow
Pavements and lots of children coming
every day and I don't personally think
that SUVs and four-wheel drives and Land
Rovers should be on these roads
Witnesses told us they saw children
underneath the vehicle as it crashed
into the school grounds cards addressed
dear Selena describe her as a shining
star an abundle of joy
I can't believe that I can't believe
that such a quiet Road and I don't know
what happened how this thing happened I
can't I can't even imagine
questions that will take time to answer
a woman her 40s thought to be a parent
or carer of a student is in a critical
condition in hospital
a number of others including a
seven-month-old baby are also receiving
treatment
at the Parish Church less than a mile
away it's the reverend's first day
her immediate task is to help this
Community start to heal this is a
devastating incident and you know
nothing like it's happened before so
very much a community and shock the
community in pain a community hurting
now that the Cordon has been lifted it's
the first time that we're able to see
the extent of the damage that was done
only a few feet away from this main road
all day people have been stopping by
having a quiet moment of peace and
reflection and adding to that growing
Garden of Flowers and messages an
acknowledgment that what happened here
has been devastating
a 46 year old woman behind the wheel of
the car who was arrested on suspicion of
causing death by dangerous driving has
been bailed pending further inquiries
the Metropolitan Police are Keen to
squash speculation and reassure people
here
but for the family of the eight-year-old
who died no amount of support Will
Repair their end of term Terror
ashnaharanak Sky News in Wimbledon
the Pentagon has confirmed that the U.S
will send cluster Munitions to Ukraine
as part of a new military aid package
Ukraine has been asking for the weapons
for months but they're controversial as
they can kill indiscriminately over a
wide area threatening many civilians and
their use well our us correspondent Mark
Stone joins me now and as we say Mark a
highly controversial this would be
effectively carpet bombing that they're
capable of
well I think that's stretching it
somewhat but it is undoubtedly
controversial uh President Biden has
said tonight in the last hour or so that
this was not an easy decision a
reflection there I think an
acknowledgment
um of the controversy surrounding these
cluster Munitions which remember are
banned by most countries around the
world almost all NATO countries with the
exception of a couple including the
United States have signed a convention a
treaty back in 2008 which bans their use
and their transfer to other countries so
why is America deciding to transfer its
existing dormant stockpile to the
ukrainians well I think it's a
reflection of the fact that the war for
Ukraine is not going well there is a gap
in supply of more conventional artillery
it is also an acceptance that the on the
ground in a military perspective these
cluster Munitions will make a difference
because if they land on the battlefield
in eastern Ukraine they will in the
short term cause huge damage to the
Russian forces there the problem is
their Legacy because these weapons
spread out
bomblets over a wide area and over a
period of time many of those do not
explode and when the war is over the
casualties are then civilian so this is
controversial but America believes that
the balance between the number of
civilians killed by Russia and the
number of civilians that could
potentially be in danger by these
cluster Munitions there is no balance
and on balance it is better to provide
these weapons now but there's no
question it is controversial and I think
many people will be very uneasy at this
decision America some arguing is losing
the moral High Ground by providing them
mark thank you
you are a highly dangerous man and you
had no thought for anyone else the words
of the judge as he gave a sentence of at
least 48 years to the man who shot dead
beautician Ellie Edwards on merseyside
23 year old Connor Chapman fired a
submachine gun into a crowd outside a
pub on the Wirral on Christmas Eve he'll
be in his 70s before he's released into
memrashid reports
for this cold calculated and Reckless
attack Conor Chapman handed a prison
sentence like no other the 23 year old
found guilty of murdering Ellie Edwards
ten minutes before Christmas day will
serve a minimum of 48 years behind bars
thought to be the longest criminal life
sentence in this country you didn't care
who else would be cool
that's why you fired all of the bullets
at the group
I'm satisfied that you are a highly
dangerous man
and if you're ever released and
considering your dangerousness that
might never happen you will be on
license for the rest of your life
evidence throughout this four-week trial
was overwhelming Connor Chapman caught
driving a stolen Mercedes onto the pub
car park an hour before his attack 12
minutes after his brutal shooting he was
spotted ruffling his long hair and
dropping the gun as he walked towards
his friend's house
and DNA covered on a red glove he wore
that night along with a bullet casing
found at the scene of the murder
as Chapman was sentenced with this
Landmark punishment some of Ellie's
family waved goodbye to the man who's
brought so much pain others shouted
scumbag but there was an overall sense
of relief inside the court that Justice
had been served the new things need to
change and we've made the start with
that and I think for 48 years
if you think of picking up a gun now you
should think twice about it Ellie's
murder last year was the fifth fatal
shooting in merseyside another ongoing
gang Feud which brought Terror to this
region streets and it was yet again this
weapon a scorpion submachine gun used in
combat which ended another life although
today was a success for this family
Christmas without Ellie will never be
the same a brother who says he's lost
everything a grandma who says she'll die
with a broken heart a father left
questioning what would have been of this
young woman's life into man Rashid Sky
News Liverpool
this week on Sky News we've been
focusing on the fast-moving world of AI
and in an exclusive interview
Microsoft's head of artificial
intelligence Eric Boyd has told us the
tech Giants determined to push ahead
with developing the technology he says
the disaster movie rhetoric that
surrounds AI leads to misunderstanding
we've also spoken to the former prime
minister sir Tony Blair who says there's
a level of ignorance about how to
regulate here's out Science and
Technology editor Tom Clarke
gpt4 is the latest AI system from openai
in 2019 Microsoft began its 10 billion
dollar investment in artificial
intelligence startup open AI the cash
and computing power it offered help give
rise to chat GPT the most powerful
language AI the world has ever seen for
Microsoft the bet is AI will redefine
people's relationship with computers we
now have machines that are so fluent in
human language every place that you
interact with the machine
ought to be much more fluent in human
natural language and I think we'll start
to see that change coming in a lot of
different places as well and it'll just
really redefine the interfaces that
we're used to the way that you're used
to talking to a machine
the chat gbt is so good at imitating
humans the red flags have shot up even
open AI admits the risks
my worst fears are that we cause
significant we the field the technology
the industry cause significant harm to
the world this led to calls to pause or
at least slow down deployment of AI do
you feel you're playing with fire as you
develop and expand these models those
concerns seem pretty far away from what
we're actually working on in the
technology that we're working on as
Microsoft sees it much of the concern is
based on misunderstanding people talk
about the AI takes over but it doesn't
have the capability to take over these
are models that produce text as output
and so we want to make sure that we work
with Regulators to say here are the
really potential benefits and let's make
sure we're leaning into those and making
that possible but one former prime
minister warns that to achieve that
involves overhauling the relationship
between big Tech and governments there
is a level of ignorance which is not
surprising and part of the problem is
you've got the change makers in one room
and the policy makers in another and one
of the things my Institute tries to do
now is put the two together China will
come at this with a different set of
priorities and perspectives but it's
also a leader in the AI field I mean
along with the US like so much else the
21st century is going to be shaped in
part by the competition between the two
in part as to whether it's possible to
cooperate Microsoft has stiff
competition Google is World leading in
its AI research it doesn't look like big
Tech is slowing down in its race for AI
Supremacy so society and our Regulators
have to speed up thinking on what the
safe AI looks like Tom Clark Sky News
for now the United States seems to be
ahead in the AI race but there's tense
competition going on with China by
introducing tougher export regulations
China has so far been blocked by America
from access to the very best chips and
Technology but as our correspondent
Helen Ann Smith reports there's one less
high-tech area where the Chinese have
the upper hand Manpower
a Chinese conference on artificial
intelligence is like a glimpse into the
future
[Music]
a display of the brightest and best in
an industry set to change the world
[Music]
a lot of things here are fun and for the
crowds
but there is also serious Innovation for
industry too
and products that will truly change
lives like this Rehabilitation Aid that
can read the body and feedback to
doctors I can't tell if I'm moving it or
it's moving me but it's a very strange
feeling
the world is watching What's Happening
Here is China winning the race to
develop and how well its capabilities be
used Baidu is China's equivalent of
Google and it's created China's best
consumer-facing chatbot and just listen
there's a pride and patriotic purpose to
this work
we believe that AI is bound to provide a
lot of support for the development of
industrial intelligence when Baidu and
Chinese Enterprises develop AI
technology we follow our president's
command setting our sights on health and
safety of the people and major
scientific needs of the country
and China is making exceptional strides
in some areas particularly in Military
and cyber security Fields it's why
America recently imposed strict new
regulations blocking China's access to
the most advanced chips and Technology
this so-called chips at is China's key
challenge in this field and it could be
extended further as that competitive
relationship with America deepens most
experts agree that China is still a
little behind the us but it does have
other strengths and advantages and some
are more traditional and to understand
that we've come here to a tiny town over
a thousand miles from Shanghai in the
rural province of guijo this place has
become known as data labeling town a
place where workers manually describe
images to teach the AI what it's looking
at
it's vital and an area China is winning
because it has an abundance of
affordable labor
so yongjang and his friend have just
arrived here they're students they tell
us and will do data labeling on the side
I feel I'm benefiting from AI he says
it's good to earn money and make a
living he adds
power is a strength then regulations
could be a drawback an experts say China
will likely go further than others the
heavy-handed regulation will hold the
industry back the sense of uncertainty
it's very unclear I think for tech
companies what's allowed and what's not
and so they're going to be very very
hesitant I think in ways that they might
not have been saying like 2015.
this industry is developing so fast it's
hard to predict what will come next but
China is a serious player and it is
catching up Helen Ann Smith Sky News in
Shanghai
Sky News has spoken to a Palestinian
militant fighter who says the recent
Israeli operation in the occupied West
Bank has only served to deepen his
resolve the Israelis have now withdrawn
from the genuine refugee camp leaving an
unusually calm with no apparent signs of
Hope for a peace process Alex Rossi
reports
the Israelis have withdrawn and a calm
has returned to the refugee camp but the
militants who were targeted remain
defiant
we would take in to meet this fighter
from one of the main brigades and he
claims although it was the biggest
military operation in two decades the
IDF achieved nothing
is
[Music]
we expected them to Target our positions
but we didn't think it would be with so
many airstrikes the Israeli Jets fired
more than 50 Rockets
we thought they'd only hit our positions
but they didn't Target us as much as
civilian areas
they only arrested one fighter and the
weapons they took were mostly for
civilians not military
our weapons are still with us the
resistance is still here and we didn't
lose anything
it's by the militant groups shows the
ferocity of the fighting as they clashed
with Israeli soldiers
this is why the Israeli military insists
they needed to act
but they've also released video of what
they claim is a bomb Factory it's still
producing dozens of homemade explosives
despite the raid and the fact the
Israelis are still watching the camp
we can hear the drones above us all the
time their presence is constant now for
decades Israel has been raiding the
refugee camp here in Janine for them
this place is a nest of terrorism but on
the streets the militants that operate
here have widespread supports they are
seen as Defenders against the brutal
military occupation
foreign
Ty prayers there is an expectation that
there will be more raids to come
Israel claims it will continue its
operations as long as necessary
the support for the militant groups is
unlikely to be broken
merged Victorious
feel Victorious all of these soldiers
and all of this shooting and we emerged
Victorious and all of those who left
their homes came back
the situation in Janine remains
extremely tense another round of
violence may not be far away and with no
political Solution on the horizon the
peace process effectively dead there's
no optimism that anything will change
Alex Rossi Sky News in the occupied West
Bank
the global shipping industry accounts
for three percent of all gases that
cause climate change now in a unanimous
agreement 175 countries have pledged to
reach Net Zero by 2050. today's deal has
been held as a positive step but
environmental groups say doesn't go far
enough our climate change correspondent
Hannah Thomas Peter reports
cargo ships are the lifeblood of
international trade but it's a polluting
business and this hard to regulate
industry has been under pressure to
clean up
now the United Nations International
Maritime organization known as the IMO
has promised for the first time to get
shipping to Net Zero carbon emissions by
or around 2050.
as you know the maritime
decarbonization strategy
has been one of the most important
profit for last over 10 years
shipping emissions are currently a big
problem global Shipping carries about 90
percent of the world's traded goods and
produces nearly three percent of all
carbon emissions about the same as
emitted by Germany every year for some
then any progress is good news what was
agreed here at the IMO in London is
the first time ever that we have a
greenhouse gas emission strategy a
decarbonization of shipping the
international shipping industry it's a
very important sector we can't say we're
ever going to abandon shipping anytime
soon it's we know that's for thousands
of years but we need to decarbonate but
as temperatures continue to rise this
week setting Global records for the
hottest days ever recorded campaigners
say the Imo's pledge is too vague weak
and lacks a delivery plan we expected
them to
um to come up with goals targets for the
global Shipping sector in line with what
it takes for their fair share for the
world to limit warming to 1.5 degrees
and unfortunately they missed a boat on
that the fuels and technology that would
drive any transition are still a long
way off for this critical industry its
journey to Net Zero likely to be an
imperfect one
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News
Belarus has said it's prepared to
welcome the Wagner mercenary group as
part of what's thought to be a deal
agreed after their short-lived Mutiny in
Russia last month Sky News has been
given a tour of an abandoned Soviet
military base with its rows of tents
could house thousands of Wagner Fighters
if they choose to move there but there's
no sign of any of them arriving yet our
Moscow correspondent Dana magnet has
this report from a military unit outside
of the Belarusian Capital Minsk
transparency apparently the order of the
day from the Belarusian Ministry of
Defense they promised they'd bring us
here to a base just south of Minsk and
here we are
the only life we find a few men asleep
but they're Belarusian nothing to do
with Wagner Mercenaries
the Belarusian leader Alexander
lukashenko had told us on Thursday that
he'd offered the Wagner group this base
and they'd said no
we do not build camps we offered them
several former military camps but PMC
Wagner have a different vision of their
encampment
what that vision is he couldn't tell us
but if they do end up here there are 300
tents at their disposal enough for 5 000
troops
so what are the immediate plans for
who's going to live here and when are
they going to move in
our main goal is to set up the
infrastructure so that if in a situation
where we have to defend our country
militarily we have the infrastructure
so Wagner have not been here they
haven't visited but they'd be welcome if
they came that is the message that we're
getting nothing to see here except for a
large training facility set up very fast
for slightly ambiguous goals
construction started right around the
time that pregojan set his men on Moscow
satellite images showing nothing here
before prego's Mutiny two days after
though already a sprinkling of tents
quiet is the nearby town of osipovic he
looks this is a military area belarus's
only ballistic missile Brigade The 465th
is based around here believed to have
recently taken delivery of Russian
nuclear-capable iskander missiles
it would make sense then for Russian
tactical nuclear warheads to have been
delivered here too but that are
Belarusian hosts would neither confirm
nor deny
foreign
Belarus
to the sport now on the third ashes test
is delicately poised heading into day
three England need to win it to have any
hope of regaining the um England Captain
Ben Stokes top scored with 80 in his
side's first innings
he smashed five sixes and six fours in
his counter-attacking knock
but he was the last man out caught off
the bowling of Todd Murphy on his ashes
debut England all out for 237 that's 26
runs behind Australia's first Innings
total
[Applause]
but Australia lost four wickets in their
second Innings mowing Ali took two of
them
mana slabuchane and Stephen Smith while
openers David Warner and Usman kawaja
both fell
Australia lead by 142 runs with six
wickets in hand
an emotional Andy Murray has hinted that
he may have played his last Wimbledon
match after his hopes were dashed 10
years to the day since he first won the
tournament the two-time champion was
defeated by Greece's Stefano sitsapas
the fifth seed in five sets hope for
British success Now lies with Katie
Bolton who's made it to the third round
Sky's Jackie Bell trout was watching
10th anniversary of winning Wimbledon
going out again in the second round
after a late night fall on Center Court
but leading Stefano sits to pass two
sets to one Murray quickly answered
questions about his Fitness as this
match went into a second day
the 24 year old was not about to crack
even Murray's lethal trademark return of
serve couldn't Forge the Breakthrough he
wanted
the inevitable tie break followed the
third of the match with the fifth seed
coming out on top this time to take it
the distance
apart longest of the March
it was a weary Murray whose serve was
broken at the start of the final set and
sits it passed 12 years his Junior with
age and the scoreboard on his side
accelerated towards the win
heartbreak again for the 2013 and 16
Champion how many wimbledon's does he
have left
I don't know to be honest
um I'm obviously very disappointed just
now
um
yeah obviously you never know how many
opportunities you're going to get to
play
um here it's six years since Andy Murray
last made it to the second week of
Wimbledon last year's semi-finalist
Cameron Nori hasn't made it this time
either and neither has Liam Brody the
underdog despite putting up a brave
fight today with no British men making
it to the first weekend at the all
England Club it's been a disappointing
day
over to you Katie Bolter the last Brit
standing in the singles this Wimbledon
Jackie beltrail Sky News Wimbledon
well that was Guy News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including a tribute to Selena Lam who's
been named as the eight-year-old girl
killed in that car crash at a school in
Southwest London yesterday
tonight I'm going to be joined by Daily
Mirror Economist Susie Boniface and
former conservative special advisor
Anita bateng you stay with us
[Music]
there's been a survey conducted which
Barclays did which which interested me
because it showed that while three
quarters of people wanted to make their
homes more energy efficient there was a
big misconception about both the time
that the works took and the cost that
they thought it was much more expensive
and much more disruptive than actually
it is
um Barclays have have the scheme's been
very popular they've got a Greener home
rewards scheme and they are offering
their existing mortgage customers up to
two thousand pounds to retrofit some of
these environmentally friendly things so
it's it's solar panels it's insulation
it's ground Source heat pumps it's
um double or triple glazing so these are
all things that are really good for the
homeowners they're really good for the
environment
um and actually they're also very good
news when it comes to selling I think
particularly now anything that puts
money in people's pockets or saves the
money and Barclays are offering up to
two thousand pounds then that's also
good news and my last home I had it all
draft
um excluded I had it tested and realized
where I was losing heat but actually my
current home my predecessor had put a
ground Source heat pump and solar panels
in so that was a real Comfort to me when
I time to choose it but I knew it
generated money actually it saved money
it's really well a good selling option
is what you're saying it is and
increasingly so
a lot of action going on I'm Alex
Crawford and I'm Skye's special
correspondent based in Istanbul
makes a job so fast
ing
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
welcome back you're watching Sky News in
just a moment the Press preview a first
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive but first our top stories
the eight-year-old girl killed after a
car crashed into her school in Wimbledon
has been named as Selena Lao
the United States has confirmed plans to
send controversial cost ammunitions to
Ukraine
and the man who murdered Ellie Edwards
outside a pub on the Wirral on Christmas
Eve has been jailed for at least 48
years
[Music]
thank you
you are watching The Press preview of
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive and it is now time to see
what's making the headlines with Daily
Mirror Economist Susie Boniface and
former conservative special advisor
Anita wetting they'll both be with us
from now until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now well the times
reports on the pressure on Rishi sunak
to give millions of public sector
workers a six percent pay rise alongside
a tribute to the eight-year-old girl
killed in yesterday's Wimbledon crash
the mirror carries the same photograph
as well as the message of thanks from
Fiona Phillips for public Support over
her Alzheimer's battle
the express reports that the Prime
Minister has been urged by fellow
conservatives to talk up brexit
The Daily Mail reveals that Westminster
has more electric cars than six major
Northern cities combined the headline
proof politicians are out of touch on
electric cars
the guardian headline reads egg or dairy
found in a third of vegan products and
also reports on Andy Murray's crashing
out of Wimbledon
Mickey Mouse versus home office the eye
reports on the removal of Disney murals
at a children's Asylum Center
the telegraph carries former BBC
chairman Richard Sharp's comments that
the wealthiest households should pay
more for the BBC
while the star reports that robots have
promised not to rebel against humans
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Daily Mirror columnist Susie Boniface
and former conservative special advisor
Anita boating welcome to you both
um we're going to start with the the
Express and the story that was on many
of the the front pages yesterday and
this is this terrible accident in
Wimbledon at um that uh School
the eight-year-old girl has now been
named by police Susie
yeah uh her name is Selena lau and apart
from the fact this is a dreadful tragedy
I didn't think I really want to talk
about it it's my daughter's only a few
months younger than her
um it's just horrific and I can imagine
what her family must be going through
yeah and it is I I can understand that I
mean it is a a very um troubling
unexpected
um heart-wrenching story because there
is no way that
anybody at the school or parents the
children could have prepared for
anything like that happening
yes
um and I I should say that that it's not
being treated as sort of Terror related
or anything like that
um and yeah it's it's a deep and
heartbreaking strategy and I think that
the family have released a kind of
really moving tribute to her as this
kind of cheeky and vivacious young girl
and it's just a deep tragedy that's it's
really being felt across um all of South
West London but the entire country um
tonight so I think all our thoughts and
prayers are definitely with the family
indeed and uh another eight-year-old
who's in a critical condition in
hospital and
um a 40 year old also in a
um critical condition
let's move to a bit of politics Morehead
to the times the front page of the times
and we read that the cabinet is split
over this uh six percent suggested uh
public sector pay rise Susie
yeah so the conservatives have got
they're all very Sticky Wicket with this
the government what's happened is that
over the past year or so uh when the
independent pay review bodies came back
and recommended a fairly lowish pay rise
from public sector inflation then kicked
in the union started saying that we need
paying more than the paid review bodies
actually said because inflation has
happened since they've made their
decision and the government said no no
no no we have to stick with what the
independent pair of your body said no
matter what and that's led to all the
strikes that we've seen throughout the
public sector now we're in a situation
where next year's award is being decided
by the same independent pay-per-view
bodies and because inflation has
happened they've made a different
calculation and so they're saying that
we have to pay so many billions more and
there's going to be roughly maybe a six
percent rise across the public sector
and that isn't just people who've been
out on strike that's the police that's
the uh that's the Border Force that's
the prison agencies that's uh the Army
the Navy the Air Force it's people that
cannot strike like as well and so having
said we've got to follow the independent
pay review bodies no matter what because
it's cheaper they're now in a situation
where the independent peer review bodies
are recommending that they pay quite a
few billion for the public sector and
that just goes against they can't
suddenly turn around and say well we're
going to ignore the independent peer
review bodies and at the same token they
can't turn around and say well something
we found billions of pounds because all
those things would make them look like
they were lying last year and what no
one is really talking about is when you
do have pay Rises for the public sector
um about ATP in every pound comes back
to the treasury in some way it grows the
economy it's a benefit it's a boon to
other people it gets spent there's tax
there's more pension payments all the
rest of it there is actually a reason
that you would economically speaking try
to grow the public sector of it or pay a
bit more money because that you know
makes all the all the Dashboard Light Up
in a positive way that this particular
government doesn't want to do that kind
of thing so it's some it's sort of stuck
in between a rock and a hard place and
the NATO in terms of the the cabinet
split um we read that five cabinet
ministers are urging Cena to respect the
recommendations of the independent pay
review bodies and that's obviously in an
attempt to prevent
um further industrial action
well yeah I think um the government is
on a Sticky Wicket I disagree with which
stick here because it's on it's on a
Sticky Wicket because the reality of
public finances inflation and
um the need to recruit and retain is a
really really difficult balancing act so
it's unsurprising that departments where
the independent pay-per-view body has
come back with sort of between roughly
sort of six
um five to six percent uh
recommendations for pay Rises are the
Departments where according to the times
ministers are sort of privately urging
that that be committed to but not from
existing budgets so it could cost as
much as sort of 5 billion to pay for all
these pay Rises which you know if that
has to come from existing Department
um existing departmental budgets would
mean them having to make really
difficult choices about how you can fund
and deal with for instance the NHS wait
list if you're also trying to give
Junior doctors a five to six percent
paid bumps so these are really really
difficult decisions and and to be clear
the reason why this is so tough is
because the government has the option of
borrowing additional money or increasing
taxes now cost of living is really
biting and so increasing taxes at this
moment where taxes are already at sort
of 30-year highs would be you know
really tough for people who are starting
to feel the pinch likewise borrowing is
more expensive than ever because
interest rates are really high to deal
with inflation so borrowing I think in
December was around sort of 17 billion
pounds for a single month which is the
highest it has ever been on the ons's
record so there really really are no
easy choices and that is why the
government has got itself it is in this
very difficult position and just to say
you know whether it would be a labor
Administration or a conservative
Administration right now they would all
face that exact conundrum and it's
exactly what's playing out across a lot
of countries in Europe
staying with politics we'll have a look
at the eye but this political story
involves Mickey Mouse Susie uh how so
yeah well apparently uh junior
immigration Minister
um Robert generic was on a visit to a
children's Asylum Center uh the other
day and reportedly saw a mural of Mickey
Mouse and some Disney characters that
were there at the entrance in the lobby
and reception and suggested that they
should be painted over because it was
too welcoming that's the report and it's
now been since painted Battlefield gray
and uh that's kind of come back to bite
him on the bum a bit because all that's
happened is that it's kind of got out
and lots of artists are now offering
their services to repaint it something a
bit more welcoming a bit more friendly
because regardless of what you think
about immigration or Robert genbrick
um children who have come here in
whatever form are not illegal they
haven't broken the law it's not against
the law to be trafficked and it's not
against the law to be brought somewhere
by your parents um they are children
and there's no harm whatsoever in having
a children's Asylum Center reception
area that is something other than
Institute additionalized and looks like
a prison so uh it all that happens is
it's another way that the Tories have
managed to make themselves look
heartless and Robert General may be a
lovely bloke their policies may not be
Harless but it's the kind of thing that
the Optics of it just make it look
incredibly heartless and then of course
if you also believe their policies are
heartless it all adds to
um perhaps why they are so far behind in
the polls when it comes around to um
people considering uh what's going to
happen in the next general election next
year Anita the Optics on this just
simply don't look good do they yeah we
read the officials accuse him of
competing with his boss the Home
Secretary Bradman to be toughest on
migration it's not a good look well I've
been it seems that you know you can get
a story about the home office is
definitely so much interest in it but I
think the reason why that is the case is
not because of stories about Optics it's
because there is a real challenge going
on in our Asylum system at the moment
where across all of Europe you have
small boats arriving
um in numbers that have not been seen
before by a lot of Western countries and
they're all grappling with the amount of
resources and time and Facilities it
would take to adequately deal with that
and this feels like a distraction
actually on both sides from the
fundamental challenge which is not being
dealt with and I think the reason why
the government is struggling is not
because people think that or I mean I
would argue it's not because people
think well the government isn't is being
heartless in its painting of murals it's
because there is a perception there
isn't a grip on this issue and I don't
think there is enough serious
conversation on either side of the
political divide about their actual
Solutions both sides seem to say well
what we want to do in labor in
particular we want to make sure we
attack the criminal gangs do you think
the government hasn't been trying to
deal with that problem this is a huge
and Incredibly naughty issue which
deserves Focus policy conversations and
agreements with countries in Europe and
not this sort of focus on are you nice
or are you not nice which is doesn't
deal with the fundamental systemic issue
around the numbers that we are seeing
and how you would manage to process them
and reach deals with other countries to
be able to remove those who are not
successful in seeking Asylum absolutely
hear your your points at loud and clear
but would have you would you have
advised Robert genwick to remove the
mural just out of Interest I just wanted
to know whether you think that was a bad
decision or not
to be honest I've never been in an
asylum Center I have no idea what's
appropriate or what's not and I have
absolutely no idea whether this story
holds any water whatsoever so I I really
wouldn't be qualified to comment okay
that's it definite no comment there um
let's move on to the express the front
page of the express
um and apparently the prime ministers
being
urged to talk up brexit he's not doing
enough to make um it a positive story
according to to his um well conservative
backbenchers it it is this time around
yes his own MPS
Susie
yep so this is Brendan Clark Smith who
is the MP for Bassett Law uh in
Nottinghamshire which is sort of
considered to be the red wall
um and he got elected in 2019 with a
fairly sizable majority on the basis of
brexit and so he is understandably
trying to say we need to talk about
brexit we need to get me re-elected
please
um Basset law at the moment it's looking
like it will go labor if there was an
election tomorrow so that's perhaps why
he's urging me she soon act to go back
and beat the the 2019 run again please
the trouble is Tori and labor are both
trying very hard not to discuss brexit
for the simple reason that it puts off a
huge number of Voters everyone's quite
Fed Up of it number one you know
everyone's bored of talking about it and
the second thing is that the latest
polls I think has won out about five
days ago showed that there is massive
support for rejoining the EU and people
are regretting having breakfast in the
first place now rejoining is fairly
ridiculous it's probably not going to
happen but that
kind of opinion poll which shows that
being the same way they don't want to
talk about the reason why they burnt
their own hand on the kettle it's
because they think just we don't want to
do it let's not anybody who therefore
says as a politician let's talk more
about brexit
is bumpers because anyone who talks
about it on any side is just inviting
trouble as far as the opinion polls and
The Ballot Box is concerned you're going
to see when that comes up to that next
general election everyone's playing very
hard not to talk about it very very hard
um I think it's going to take some time
probably before the general public wants
to talk about it again as well
you might be right on that uh Susie
underneath we're going to take a break
there we're going to take a break there
do stay with us coming up but we'll
discuss this story on the front of the
telegraph that the U.S could back
Britain over Ukraine NATO bid it's been
with us for more on that and Other
Stories
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me Daily Mirror
Economist Susie Boniface and former
conservative special advisor Anita
wetting let us have a look at the
telegraph front page in this story and
suggesting that Joe Biden is considering
backing British plans to Fast Track
Ukraine's entry into NATO Anita
yes this is a really interesting
um story it's ahead of the NATO Summit
in Lithuania uh next week and um
basically after Joe Biden said quite
recently that there would have to be the
same rules that you know apply to
Ukraine as others which basically means
you have to have this membership action
plan where you undergo military and
diplomatic reforms before you can join
NATO now the U.S representative to Nato
Julian Smith has indicated that that
NATO allies might agree next week at
this NATO Summit in Lithuania to have
Ukraine forego having one of those
action plans which would put it on a
fast track um so I think a very
interesting development and maybe a sign
that the kind of UK approach that has
been more I guess gung-ho about getting
Ukraine um closer into NATO is paying
dividends the other interesting part of
the telegraph story is that Biden is
going to stop off in the UK again
um to meet the king for the first time
well I mean the first time asking and
also to meet um sunak once more to sort
of compare notes and this is the fifth
time that they have met and clearly a
sign that relationships between
um Joe Biden and Richie sunaka certainly
very warm and it feels as though the
trip that sunak made
um a few months ago to the US really was
a kind of turning of the tide in their
relationship and a sign that they are
becoming much closer Allied
yes and Susie the um Mr Biden only said
last month that the US wasn't going to
make it easy for Ukraine to join the
defense block because they've got to
meet the same standards uh quote as
everyone else's existing members so
something seems to have changed does it
not
decided to turn around towards Moscow
um obviously what's happened and is
nothing's changed in the sense that you
as Biden said you do still have to and
as an intercept you do still have to
meet with the requirements to join NATO
that hasn't altered and there's no way
that they could have sort of a second
string to Nato or a second class version
but um what has altered is that Putin's
um strength has completely been
obliterated such as it was anyway as
head of unarmed forces that wasn't doing
very well it's been obliterated by the
attempted coup
um his time in office is probably
ticking down to an inevitable
defenestration at some point which is
his favorite method of dealing away with
them with people
um and therefore the long process of
getting
can perhaps perhaps begin because what's
Putin gonna do he's going to Rattle the
saber a bit but although he's a
nuclear-armed nation he hasn't used his
weapons yet he's very unlikely to and
the chances are now that he doesn't have
the support within his own forces to
actually be able to do that anyway even
if he decided to press the button and so
Biden has perhaps reasonably seen that
the time is ripe to move a bit and have
some NATO expansion interesting uh we've
just got about a minute or less Anita's
talk about the tennis and Andy Murray
could this be the last time we see him
playing at Wimbledon he says I may not
come back next year
yes he was clearly very crushed um so
this is obviously the 10th anniversary
of Murray winning Wimbledon
um you know and losing to someone who's
sort of 12 years younger than him
probably underscored the point that he's
been in this game for a very long time
um and it's been six years since uh
Murray's made it to the um second week
of Wimbledon and it's clearly been a
challenging moment so who knows what how
he'll feel wants to sort of you know the
agony of the immediate loss um kind of
fade somewhat but yeah certainly really
devastating for those big Murray fans of
which I'm sure we were all
thank you both Anita and Susie we shall
see you at the top of the hour Anita and
Susie staying with us for the 11 but in
the meantime let's take a look at the
weather for you
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
for weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well Saturday is promising to bring us
some very active weather as some heavy
thundery downpours sweep across the
country in Scotland and Central and
Eastern England it'll be warm and humid
from the word go it will also be bright
with generous amounts of sunshine in the
southwest it will be quite windy with
some showers affecting parts of Ireland
Northern Ireland Wales and Southwest
England
the showers will push northeastwards
during the day intensifying as they do
so we can expect some heavy downpours
Gusty winds hail and frequent lightning
so the Met offers this warning that
there could be some disruption
weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
coming up next on Sky News at 11 the
eight-year-old girl killed after Carr
crashed into a school in Wimbledon is
named